in our ion money series the IRS is
warning taxpayers about the top 12 tax
scams it calls the Dirty Dozen the
agency is announcing one fraud each day
in this morning the IRS is revealing its
latest scam on the list dishonest tax
preparers it's previously announced
identity theft phone scams and phishing
scams these three appeared on last
year's list as well
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what you need
to know this tax season Jill good
morning great to have you here
let's start with phishing email scams
because they jump 60% from 2017 to 2018
what should you do if you do get a
suspicious email well first of all you
have to recognize it is a suspicious
email and this is what's tricky because
sometimes an email comes from something
that's close to an organization that you
know so you you know the kind of the gig
here there's a website you click on it
asking for information and you give up
that information then the fraudster uses
your information files a fraudulent
return gets the refund sent to him or
her and then when you go to file your
taxes oh my god a return has already
been filed so what do you do you don't
open anything that looks remotely
suspicious it's really important you
don't click on any hyperlinked websites
you don't open attachments you
absolutely should forward this to the
IRS it's fishing at irs.gov
the mail be safe you know this happened
to my dad actually put this in the book
and it was like the essence of the smart
person who does something really dopey
hey I heard from this organization
before it looked like an organization he
had given money to but it was different
we conduct so much of our life over
email these day so how can you tell if
you do get a real email from the IRS
well first of all there are some of
these fraudsters are so canny that
they're using IRS forms in the email
header and so one thing that's really
important is that you go to irs.gov and
if you've got some form number or claim
number or issue number that you then can
say to the IRS hey is this real so again
so much information at irs.gov please
use it it's actually your tax dollars at
work really well
phone scammers targeting consumers as
well you said what you said the
greenroom hang up right hang up okay so
this is really important it's not just
your landline anymore it is two cell
phones and these are robo calls and they
are really aggressive so what you're
gonna find is that if someone is on the
phone oh they say I'm from the IRS arm
from a collection agency that's your red
flag the IRS generally will not call you
and start a conversation this way it's
so important so you want to hang up be
careful don't give information and any
question at all just say no hang up
there are a lot of meet and unethical
people in this country Jill and it
doesn't always happen at tax season
year-round every all your round and the
scams change a little bit but be on
alert
great point thank you Joe